A
Thank you. Thank you for taking time out.
Yeah.
Wait here for Cindy to join us.
Sure.
Yeah.
Oh, Cindy's gonna join us for a couple.
Who?
Looks specific.
You're working from home?
Yeah, I work from home.
How far is your place from the office, Summit office?
I am like 20 minutes, so it's not bad.
Ohh, that's nice.
Yeah, it's not bad at all.
So, yeah, you can clearly, I mean, get to your office, I mean, if required.
So, we're just not in the office much, so let me see if Cindy's gonna join us, let me message her.
Nice.
Okay.
Hey, sir, how's the weather in Noida?
Ohh, it's pretty hot.
Yeah.
So then if you don't know, when the server works from different site of ITBD from NC or Noida, yeah.
Hey, Vishal.
Ha.
Hi, Cindy. Good afternoon. How have you been?
Ohh.
Hi, how are you? Good, good. Hi.
Good afternoon, Cindy.
Now we see you from different camera angle. We see your office now.
Oh yeah, no, yeah, I'm actually in the office today. Usually at home. Yeah, usually I'm at home, but today I'm in the office.
She's in our office today, funny you know.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Nope.
Nice.
So.
Yes, Jason, over to you.
Couple things, just we're going to share a little bit of feedback that some good and some stuff that might need just a little bit of follow-up coaching with Akhilesh. So
Mm.
There is a ticket that is probably a pretty good example to kind of go through a couple coaching things. And I, to be honest with how much I've got project wise and stuff, Gagan, I don't know how much often you meet with him, but if you could help me with it, it would be fantastic. So I'm going to share my screen for a minute and just kind of go through.
Mmh.
Here, we already made some adjustments to the to this, right?
The one thing that I still had to follow up on is kind of this first note. So we have this, this like half hour time entry, right?
Mhm.
That is.
Just information.
It doesn't say anything what was done. Now, I know that we've coached him since this time entry on putting better notes in, so fantastic, right? But I need to know on this one because if he actually did engineering, I need to know that that needs to get in the ticket note. Otherwise, I can't bill for this half hour.
Yeah.
How to write it off?
Sure, Jason. I'll check with him. So this is for May 5th.
Yep, and I can put in this chat the service ticket. And it's the very first half hour time entry.
And, uh...
Yeah, sure.
Yep, thank you.
Mhm.
Um...
The other thing is, and I think we covered this with him, but a good refresh is that if he is working with an engineer.
that is going to help him and he's learning. He needs to no bill his time, make it customer service or something like that. And then the engineer will bill their time. So we went back and changed this to be no bill.
Mhm.
The.
And so that's just one correction there.
Took my first call.
The one that's more prevalent that I think could use some coaching is when we're sending emails, client comms.
Ben was my predecessor.
He's doing that. He needs to use the customer service charge code, so it comes up as no charge. He was doing it as billable. So if he's just sending one-way client communication, he needs to change that to customer service.
Sure.
So there's a couple in here that we went through and changed.
Um...
The other one that I was looking at, was it this ticket or which ticket was it? I had the good notes, but...
Cindy.
She's got somebody I think she's talking to.
And second, I promised him somebody would call.
Right, I can take care of it, right? I'm sorry, go ahead.
The.
Take it that had the better notes from the really good notes that he had, but the time entry could should have been probably reversed. Which one was that? Do you recall?
That was from today, right?
Um...
Mhm.
Yeah, um, let me look.
Was it fine? I think it was finding us forward.
OK, and I can get to that by looking at his.
Um...
Here, switching over to Dubey.
Okay.
So his notes are pretty good here. Like he's got good notes here. He still really should be, I guess he used it here earlier, but these notes, he should be using still that same format.
Yeah, the um, detail or not detail, I'm sorry, just the standard note that has.
But the content is really good. I really like his email that he sent.
Mhm.
The email was really good.
However...
I can't, if he does just send an email, I can't bill for it. In this case, we're going to leave it as is because this client's all inclusive. But what should have happened was he sent this email.
And this time entry should have been from 10 to 1036.
and encompassed the time it took to write that email.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, it does. Thank you. And I know that you had, yeah, you had reiterated this or communicated this when Marcus was here on this account, you know, about this email thing. So this is something I think you are, you have started implementing recently, right? It was not an old practice.
Because I can't build that extra time.
I mean, it should have been. It's just a clarification, I think. So, but again, I think that his email was great. It's just, again, at coaching. This doesn't come off to me as, oh my God, what is he doing? But if he does it the other way, I can bill for that 6 minutes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Mhm.
If I don't do it, I can't bill because it doesn't look like any work was done. I know the value add, but if it's not done in that other reversed order, I can't bill for it. You know, in one ticket, it's not a big deal, you know, but over the course of a week, you know, it could be the difference of a couple hours worth of billing.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
You know, so it could be 3 to 400 hours worth of difference in billing. That's all.
Mhm.
Yeah, again, not.
The biggest concern.
But it's a, but it's a, it's definitely something if you don't mind, if you meet with him to kind of go through. I could pop this one in here, but I would definitely make sure to share with him the positive feedback of the notes and everything. Like, like his email looks good and everything.
Mm-hmm.
You know, I have a tendency to look at the stuff we can do better on and forget about all the good stuff, so yeah, that's just me.
Thank you.
Absolutely, no, thank you. We always love to hear from you and that is the only opportunity that helps us always do better because otherwise we feel we are just stagnant, stuck on the same thing, a repeater thing that we are doing on day in, day out. So thank you for highlighting that. And
I'm sure.
Thank you. First of all, you did highlight notes. Those are from May 5th. I mean, a couple of notes, you know, those needed attention. And yes, we did have a call just a few days back. So did you observe those kind of non-available charge code mistakes, you know, afterwards, after we connected the last time?
Well, the, I'm, I can't speak to that to say that I've seen just emails going out. I don't, did we have a conversation with him about not billing for just straight emails? Because this one was today. So if you, if you take that.
The finance forward ticket that has two entries, right?
Mhm.
No, sorry, not specifically. I'm asking for...
I had to change, I had to change this. This I left is billable because it's unlimited, but this based on the conversation, if we had a prior conversation, the answer would be no, he's not because this time entry right here.
Technically, it should be customer service.
which is why we want to reverse it so that that way we can include in the entry that goes to the client that shows the value of the work that he did.
Mhm.
encompasses the whole thing and then you can just send the email along, you know.
Okay.
So, if I'm if I'm getting it correct, Jason, instead of internal node, there should have been a client using node - that's what you're saying.
So...
No, this is a client-facing note, but what he did was he did all of his work.
logged the time entry for doing his work. Then he spent an extra 5 minutes drafting an email.
Okay.
Yeah.
So, Vishal.
And then he sent it another time entry for that that email, right? So...
Understood. Got it, got it. Now I understood. Yeah.
What he could do in reverse is he could even prep the time entry, the entire time entry, but what he should have done was sent the email out with like a no bill time entry and then sent out the very last thing, the time entry that covers all the work, which can say emailed client.
Yep.
Additional 6 minutes that could have been in the billable time over there, understood. In this case, yeah.
Yeah, so it would have been, yeah, so basically the time entry at the top would have been inserted inside of the same time frame as the other, so that that way we're not having to no bill the time corresponding.
That's really the only time that we expect to see a small time entry for an email is when it's only correspondence, right?
Ohh, get that.
It's just not fair to build 15 minutes, 15 minutes, 15 minutes for five-minute emails, but it is important to capture the entire, yeah, so we just want to capture it in there so that way it comes out right. Does that make sense?
In addition, yes.
Yeah, so going forward, he can include his entire Nord's troubleshooting steps into that one email that he's sending to the client and mark time as whatever is the actual time, including email and troubleshooting. Is that right?
Um...
Yes.
Okay.
I would encourage to have a word with him, just try to get his understanding around this process. It's very important he understands, he has the in-depth analysis or he understands the ask over there. If he's, this is something which is still not clear, we can just, you know, just get in touch with Jason and we can just try to figure it out. He's new on this account, right? So.
Yeah.
But it is very, it is important, right? As Jason rightly said, it could be 6 minutes miss, billing missing on one ticket. But if you just calculate it for the entire month, it could be two hours. So it could be more than that. So I think this is, yeah, important piece.
Absolutely, Vishal. I can really get what Jason is emphasizing, and Jason, the only reason is I know every client is different, so I mean, in my entire life, I mean, we had we had been doing like that, so you know, people you know used to you know build both of these two things separately.
Yep, yep.
But, yeah, understandable. This is a, you know, minor change at our end. We can, we can make that.
Yeah.
It's an oddity that I would love to get rid of, but it's just, and I honestly think it's from some historical past of us doing different things. I don't think I'm with you a bit on it, but that's just kind of how we have to do it. And again, it's not the craziest
thing, it's 5 minutes, right? But it's a coaching that's worth going through. The one thing that did come that was maybe concerning, I haven't had a chance to speak with him though, but was today he went on a break.
Yep, I agree. Yep.
and then didn't check back and then went on lunch after. So it looks like he was gone for almost an hour and a half. I don't know if that was the case or not or what the deal, what happened there. Maybe he didn't just check back in. I don't know. But if you could kind of take a look, Cindy, what was the chat log from our
Because you know, we have the group chat that we check in and out of. I think you're familiar with that, Gagan.
Because he's been doing that, he's usually pretty good about that. So I think around what, 1015 did he check or what?
He went to break at 10:32, and then he went to lunch at 11:44.
And what time did he come back from lunch?
I don't have any check back in.
But I have him green, so...
I, I don't think he checked back in.
So I don't know what happened. It looks like he has time at 12. So maybe he was back. I don't know. But if you could follow up on that, Gagan, just make sure he's checking in and out and mainly checking back in. And if he forgets to, just say, oh, I forgot. As long as it's only every once in a while, I mean, we're not, I did it today.
Yep.
Mm.
Because I got a call as I sat down or something. I don't remember why, but if it's like all the time, then yeah, a big problem there, but you know.
Completely, I completely understand, and this is very, very important for us to have whereabouts of our engineers, because I mean, otherwise Cindy will not get to know when she needs to assign a ticket, you know, absolutely. So, I'll ask him to, you know, at my end is also, or Cindy, what we can do if...
So, exactly.
It is feasible. We can't be in one group and whenever he leaves for break, I mean, he can just mention, you know, going on break when he's back and, or does he have to enter this information on a specific tool?
I mean, I would just...
Mm.
I just ask him, you know, if it was me, I just ask him, hey.
Share your screen for group chat.
Seriously.
Yeah, share your, share your, yeah, see, that's all we do.
Yep.
Be right back, back. Be right back, back.
Oh, he's like tagging.
Yeah.
But I can't see that.
Right.
Okay, so he is, but he's tagging it, but it's really hard to tell, especially here. So if he could just, rather than tag him back to the lunch, it makes it really hard, not chronologically. So if he could just change that, that's fine. He is barking back.
Yeah.
But I can't tell when.
Okay.
So, just a little...
He's following his own way, but you know, I can reiterate the way he needs to do it. Sure.
You know, yeah, yeah, yeah, just tell him to write back, you know, it's...
Okay.
Because if the group chat gets hit up and I'm down here, I'm not going to see that.
Yeah, sure. Thank you.
OKOK, that makes sense then. Cool.
And Jason, just one quick confirmation for the time sheet entries. Do we have any SOP or even a single feature that we can share with Akhilesh so that he's aware what kind of time entries needs to be selected with which particular partner or client?
So I don't necessarily have that. And Cindy, earmuffs, but not really earmuffs, you're fine. I'm just saying that for that. There is a very, very high probability that we are going to go to something like Halo very soon.
Mhm.
I'm excited and nervous all the same. So, but so I don't, I right now, to be frank, I'm not spending any time writing in any SOPs around anything that would be tied to something like that because it's going to change.
Now, I'm excited.
I hear you.
And, and there is nothing to be nervous about, hello.
So the nice thing is, is that I can then, with the change, I'll just be like, here, here's all the nice new documentation. Don't have to worry that how long have I been here and I don't have that doc? That's kind of a basic thing. So yeah.
Good.
And trust me, we have a team of experts for Halo at ITBD because we already use that. And so if you need any assistance in setting up or do anything, so we can help you with that.
We.
I don't think I'll need help with setup or anything like that, but I don't know what our contract or what resources we have that are included at no additional cost, because, you know, obviously for doing all that, we're throwing some money around right now to do that. But if there's any resources there from somebody that does use it, that
could give me a service manager insight into it. I would love that, but my boss won't go for anything that's going to cost us money, to be honest with you. And it's OK if there's not anything.
Any minor thing, any minor thing, you know, you know, I can handle that without any money getting involved.
Okay. Yeah, I just, I mean, because my thing looking at it is I think it's going to be, I can't think of how do you do this ConnectWise thing in Halo. I need to like reset.
and just learn Halo because I feel like it's going to operate very differently.
Yeah.
Is that the feeling that you get? Like, I don't know how much you know of ConnectWise and all that, but I feel like...
Like we used Ninja so different than we did the other because it just functions.
Differently.
So much better.
Yeah, it's like you go in and you have the information you should have and you don't have to do 6 million things.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
So I kind of feel like that's what's going to happen with Halo.
Halo is also pretty good, and because previously we did used to have separate BrightGauge, because we didn't have any gauges in with the other tool, ConnectWise, Management, or other things, but with Halo, I think it has some automation built in AI stuff, even if you need to write an email.
I mean, you do not need to add any Grammarly or anything to modify your email sentences or anything. So that looks more formal and accurate. So it does most of the things on its own. So that's really helpful. Yeah. And yeah, I mean, I think it is saving cost for BrideGage as well.
Nice.
Um...
Well, there's several things that would roll into that. That's why I don't have anything official. I just, I don't know. I've worked here long enough to know.
When my bosses seem intrigued enough to be...
moving on something and I feel like with all the things that we can roll into one, it's going to probably, I feel like it's probably going to happen. You know, so I'm excited for that, but yeah.
Okay, thank you. So, Jason, thank you for sharing your feedback. Coming back to those points, so your feedback has been captured, board, you know, charge codes, you know, those need to be billable on the ticket. And yeah, I understand previously his ticket notes, I mean,
You shared that ticket number with me. I'll, yeah, absolutely. I'll check those, you know, what exactly notes he needed to have on those tickets. Apart from that, Cindy, I know currently, I mean, you are giving me leverage. You're not burdening him with a lot of stuff.
The 2 tickets, yeah.
So he is not being bombarded, but so are you are you currently happy with this current utilization? I see his his daily, yeah.
No.
But now I need to, again, stand up for my engineers. He's also answering the phones. He has been answering the phones because we've had a lot of people going on site. So he doesn't necessarily work the ticket.
Yeah.
but he will answer the phones. And so, yeah, as far as the amount of work he's doing, yeah, he does what, you know, he's getting his feet wet. He's doing things. He did call me. I don't remember what day it was, but I told him to call me, you know, if he had any questions.
I get off at 430. He ran into, I think it was like 445 or something. He called me and he, which he was supposed to, and he wanted to know what to do with the ticket and he did it. So, so yes, he is following, following that. I think 50, I've already been over it. So it's not really,
complaining, but there was a couple tickets that we just need to look a little closer and pick up some key information, like a BitLocker key. He was sending it for the user's machine, but the user was on a different machine and sent a screenshot.
But now he knows where to look. Everybody is giving the feedback of he's new.
And he's trying to, you know, to get our way of doing things, you know, under his belt. He is checking in and out. He is appearing on the morning meetings. And he does ask for work. So he does let me know if, you know, if there's any, if he needs some tickets.
Mhm.
Some of the tickets are taking a little bit longer, but it's also a learning curve.
Yep.
I would say to sum it up, we're satisfied with where he's going, but there's still room to, there's places, there's feedback and coaching, which is to be expected, so.
Absolutely. And I, because he sits on the same floor, so I get to speak to him on a daily basis. And I try to review his board on a daily basis. If it's best for one day, we connect the other day, the next day. And I ensured that
if there is any kind of requirement in terms of upgrading his skill set on a specific technology or maybe on a specific process. So, you know, I must, you know, I must know that from him so that before he starts to making mistakes.
We upskill him and we coach him and groom him with those required trainings and everything. Yeah, so thank you for sharing this. This is very, very helpful. You know, as you know, our Teams Federation is always open.
Yeah.
And that would be a good opportunity so that we do not even wait for these calls. Anything, I mean, if that comes to your notice.
We do, you know we do. I didn't, I forgot that we had a call, so I was like, hey, you got a minute? And I was like, I'm gonna call later. Let's just talk a bit, you know.
Yeah.
Yeah, and trust me, most of the times we have teams, you know, on our phones as well. So, but if you have a break, there may be a delay of five to seven or 10 minutes, but when we are in system, you will get a reply right away. So thank you.
Das.
how much effort you guys bring with just a single engineer to us. So it's, you know, I've always been very satisfied. So, you know, thank you.
No, yeah.
Thank you, Jason. And I'm blessed that I'm working with ITBD and our culture is such. We have not just, you know, these technical and other trainings, we do have leadership trainings as well, and that help us, you know, improve to, you know, from our current level to, you know,
the level we aspire to be on. Yeah. So thank you for sharing this. And I'm happy what we're doing is being depicted in our actions. Thank you. Serb, anything from your end? We didn't give you a chance.
Kour.
No worries. Thank you so much, Jason, for the insightful feedback. That will definitely help us allow to move to your expectations. Talking about the things which I wanted to quickly confirm with you, I have seen that you haven't registered for our build it event, so that's...
Excuse me, that's our annual event. So let me bring it on the screen so that I can share more information related to the event. I will send you the details in the chat window so that you can have it. So this is 8th event in the row. This time we are taking our partners to New York Stock Exchange. Prior to this, we were able to take our partners to NASA, to Kennedy Space Center. Before that, it was Statue of Liberty.
team at Life Stadium. So this is 8th year in the row. This is happening in August, August 3rd to 5th. That's happening on New Jersey, Hyatt Regency. The focus primarily, it's more on the managed intelligence as of right now with the AI getting implemented in most of the things so that what our CEO focuses, more than 550 attendees from
across the MSP channels will be attending, 70 plus channel influencers would be there. We have already got 50 plus tools and templates, which you can always implement it within your system, and then zero sales pitches. So this is the focus for the Build It Live 2026. This event is for three days and for last.
date, that's on August 5th, as I mentioned earlier, we will be going to New York Stock Exchange for the after hours party. The theme will be great gets by theme, so you have plenty of time to get the tuxedos there. Rest, talking about the speaker, we will have John C. Maxwell, Dan Sullivan coming in, and then plenty of
Okay.
CEOs from Red Hem from Tribe. So this is one thing that I would definitely want that you and your leadership team would be there. And as an early bird offer, though the ticket current price is 1495, I will mention you a code which will allow you to get.
It.
the ticket at half the price, so it will be BOGO offer. With one ticket, you will get one off. And in case if more members will be coming in from your leadership team, you can always let me know. I'll check if what the best way we can help you out. And for the room bookings, as well as for the rest of the details, if
Required, you can always ping me on the teams. I'll share you the link, and this is what I was.
Yeah, I'm looking at this and what I would probably do is, you know, it looks like you got a speaker from Halo there and stuff. So this might be a little bit more relevant than prior for us. What I would probably do is run this past my leadership and see, Cindy, you're not allowed to go anywhere ever. You just go to the off. No, I'm just messing with you.
Okay.
Yes.
And me.
Play.
I know, I know.
You're not allowed to go actually out. No, no, you're fine. I'll see, you know.
Yeah.
I'll see what they normally do for these kind of things. Is that the best pricing that would be there? Or I know that as we get down to the wire on a lot of these things, sometimes you even just throw a whole free and then 1 1/2. We're just changing so many tools right now. We're throwing money there. So if it's something valuable to them,
Quick.
Yeah.
Um, you know, if my team isn't is um...
interested, I would say do whatever you can to entice them if they do become interested. So what I'll say, but yeah, I'll go run this past Leo and Kim and let them know. So you said there's going to be a lot of AI strategy.
Mhm.
Surely.
Yes, so that's the agenda right now for three days. So we have a Pre one day event for our partners who are already a part of AI MSP Mastermind. That's like a peer group for our partners who are focusing currently on AI implementation. So this is August 3rd agenda, and then this is for
the breakout sessions for August 4th. So the focus is more on AI, the future, and not only for the AI, we have the leadership breakout rooms, we have it for operations, for growth, for sales, for HR team. So let me know how many members will be coming in. I can definitely check out what the best which we can do for you. And this is for the.
last day. The focus on the last day will be more aligned on the AA accelerator program. So this day is dedicated to AA accelerator specifically. And then the last day, that's the after hours party. So I'll send this one out so that you can have it for your reference.
I'm not allowed to go to after-hours parties anymore.
Red Kobe.
Okay, so I believe the focus will be.
I'm just joking.
But I am.
Cindy could go as my Chopra, and she'll make sure I'm alright.
If.
That's.
Um, you know.
He wouldn't let me go to India either. That's where I really wanted to go. I wanted to ride an elephant.
Yeah.
You know.
But.
The Cindy for that.
Yes, and every year you say that you will visit a new, but you never.
Someday, yes.
So Cindy for that, we are also planning something in the year end and we will definitely share you, we'll keep you posted that specifically a partner retreat and you can definitely bring your members along with you. And once Gagan will be sending out the email for the quick recap, minutes of meeting, I'll send out all the information over in separate email, Jason. And let me know in case if you would like me to include
Mhm.
Hmm.
Okay, great.
someone else from the leadership team, I'll reach out to you.
I sent the link already to Kim, just saying this may be more relevant this year for us. And then I'll let her look and see and go from there.
Awesome.
Perfect.
Appreciate it.
You know, with it being close enough to drive and not have to fly, those things become enticing. And, you know, depending upon what kind of deals you get, maybe it would be. And I know that we're big, AI is very big in our marketing side of things too. So just had to take a look and see.
True.
Okay.
We would love to have you there, Jason. Thank you so much for that. And just to keep you updated, we have done plenty of innovations in terms of AI, which we have implemented it internally as well. We have created digital dispatchers, so who can take care of ticket assignments. Even the Cindy would be worried about this. And then we have L1 plus.
Don't say that in a setting.
Oh, not worried about it.
Beating.
So we are focusing more on having the digital workforce while working along with the human workforce. And then we have QVR automation, how you can monetize it for your end users too. So this is something which you and team can definitely look forward for.
Yeah.
Kip.
I mean.
All jokes aside, a AI driven or tool that helps to dispatch would be helpful because then rather than Cindy having to run all over the place for stuff, she could focus on helping the actual tickets get done and moving around and working the exceptions more.
and not have to cover the front end as much. You know, I joke to say, don't say that because, you know, it's Cindy's our dispatcher, but I feel like Cindy's more than our, well, she's not technically, she's our coordinator. So, you know.
True.
Look.
Nice.
So that's her actual title is coordinator. She's not, she does a lot of stuff. So getting her away from the, I guess, the overhead of the dispatch.
I'm not worried.
I am totally not worried.
No, I know you're not worried, but I, but that would, but I feel like that would get you into your real skill set that's more valuable to the company, you know, not having to be on the dispatch triage side of things as heavily and.
Joke.
You are so right.
You are 100% right, which means I should go to New York.
And then, probably.
True, that's what I was coming to, so you will have plenty of time, Cindy.
Is it there though one title, you know, I feel for Cindy that is Chief, you know, Happiness Officer at Summit. Yeah, so.
Yeah.
But.
The.
Aww, thanks.
Unless she's talking to me, then she's, no, I'm just, she's giving me a hard time. No, that's all right. Yeah, no, Cindy, honestly, look at this and we can see if it's what value it'll have and things like that and we can look. Especially what caught my eye to think that there could be some stuff is with.
A.
Yeah.
I do.
You know, with Halo being there as well, too, it might just it might be very relevant to the things that we're doing.
Very cool, very cool.
Sound.
Definitely. Thank you. Over to you, Gagan.
Ohh.
Yeah, thank you, Sarah, for sharing this. And Jason, so we already knew that what this call needed to be about. And thank you for sharing good feedback for Akhilesh, where he needs to improve on. So which is why I mean, I know this meeting was completely focused on the back of resource, Akhilesh, that is aligned with Summit.
Kour.
OK, great.
Over the call right now, and...
How is Manish doing? Any word?
I didn't receive any update from past two days, I would say, but I have scheduled my call with his family for tomorrow. So, but as for the last update, he's making progress and so I'm sure, you know, things will be moving on, are moving on the positive side.
Pre.
Good, good. I really miss her.
Yeah.
Absolutely, I, I too.
Yeah, we do.
I do. I really miss him. He was like, he's part of our family. So yeah, I really miss him.
Yeah, so last time when I called, you know, someone else, a mail person picked up a call in his family and I thought, oh, is it Manish? He said, no, I, you know, his relative. So, so I was very happy, you know, I thought it is Manish, but yeah, I'm also missing to.
Well, send our best, you know.
Yeah.
He just shares A lot. He's not just, you know, here to do a job and move along. You know, it's been really, it's been a great pleasure, you know, around some of the holidays and stuff. We talk and get to know a little bit more about what he's doing with his family. He's even shared that and I've shared it with my son, some of the stuff as he's had questions about holidays and it's just,
Absolutely.
Drew.
You know we miss him, so just send our best to him and hopefully he's back soon.
Absolutely. Thank you, and I'm happy that, besides ITBD, he had, you know, second family, Summit Business Technology. I was thinking too much about him, so thank you, you know, being a part of...
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So that is coming from my end. Sorry, I meant it took 5 minutes extra, but we had really good, meaningful conversation. And yeah, absolutely. So we'll meet again and with the positive updates, and I'm sure you'll see some changes as for the feedback that you shared today. Vishal, before we drop off.
It's worth it.
Mhm.
Yes.
Okay, dok.
Is there anything from your end?
No, I'm good. Just struggling with my camera. Apologies for that. But thank you, Jason, for all the feedback and hopeful and excited to see you in Build It. Thank you so much.
Awesome. Thank you.
Yeah, thank you, Jason. Thank you, Sandy, and everyone. Have a great day. Yeah, bye, everyone.
Thank you, Cindy. Thank you, Jason. Goodbye.
Hi.
Right.